bonsoir aujourd'hui 30 juin 2015
nouvelle édition du journal de la
rédaction merci de nous rejoindre sur tv
fil 78 2 voici les principaux titres
la vague de chaleur annoncée est
finalement arrivé il a fait chaud très
chaud dans les yvelines cela devrait
durer les records vont-ils tomber le
point avec les prévisionnistes de météo
france dans l'actualité locale également
la colère des parents d'élèves qui
persistent attrape une partie d'entre
eux ne digère pas la nouvelle
organisation des rythmes scolaires et la
tarification qui se met en place pour
septembre et puis le plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal de 50 ans du
vignes étudié par le cos des skis le
conseil de développement livre remarqué
avis ce sera tout à l'heure en plateau
avec nos invités
le préfet des yvelines a donc activé ce
mardi le niveau 3 du plan départemental
de gestion de la canicule une attention
particulière est apportée aux personnes
les plus fragiles mais il est conseillé
à tous de boire régulièrement de l'eau
de s'abriter dans des lieux frais et
d'éviter de pratiquer une activité
physique à noter aussi le renforcement
est d équiper du quinze numéros à
composer en cas de malaise pour la suite
de la période estivale un point doit
d'ailleurs être fait du comité
départemental canicule réunion prévue le
8 juillet en attendant à certains
métiers sont plus impacté que d'autres
comme la restauration aux premiers
rayons de soleil les terrasses se
remplissent mais de préférence sous les
parasols petit micro-trottoir de ses
terrasses de café justement pour savoir
comment les saint quentinois vivent ces
températures avec william el est patrick
jacques de dixmude qui sont allés se
désaltéraient dès qu'il ya 2-3 à lyon
soleil la terrasse et complète les gens
me le palais l'intérieur préfère aller
dehors donc bah c'est un peu étouffant
c'est un peu
on s'épuise beaucoup plus vite en fait
je crois que 90 % disent qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui c'est ta salade voilà
énormément de carafes d'eau
on a pris une grande salade chacune
crudités à bâton
saumon fumé ce n'était pas si frais que
ça mais vous au bas doit on fraîche en
été comme hiver je bois de l'eau à litre
et demi par jour donc de toutes façons
ça chez la canicule ne fera rien changé
ma voiture ayant la climatisation
tout va bien j'ai déjà du mal quand il
fait pas chaud mais alors quand il fait
très chaud c'est encore pire parce que
dehors
pour moi c'est un supporter la chaleur
est bien présente et cela devrait donc
durer mais sommes nous en train de
battre des records dans notre
département des yvelines les réponses
avec les prévisionnistes de météo france
installé à trappes avec mélanie poker
patrick jacques de dixmude casquette
ombrelles et repas à l'ombre
l ile de france connaît depuis cet après
midi un pic de chaleur
en cause un anticyclone qui arrive du
sahara au fur et à mesure comme ses
terres en remontant ils se réchauffent
progressivement vu qu'ils rencontrent
des sols de plus en plus chaud et sec
comme il n'a pas plu depuis une bonne
quinzaine de jours le thermomètre ainsi
tutoyer les 35 degrés aujourd'hui le
précédent record pour cette période date
de 1947 avec plus de 35 degrés mais le
spectre de la canicule de 2003 avec des
températures atteignant les 40 degrés
est toujours là tu peux être un élément
aggravant
c'est que ça arrive en début de période
parce que comme vous le savez bon il ya
un certain retard entre le soleil qui
est à son maximum le 21 juin
l'atmosphère et met un certain temps
pour se réchauffer et donc les
températures maximales qu'on a c'est
disons entre le
15 juillet et puis le 31 juillet un
passage nuageux est prévue pour la
journée de jeudi les températures
devraient diminuer mais très légèrement
la fin du pic est prévu au plus tôt pour
jeudi matin 7 heures autre sujet je vous
propose de découvrir à présent cette
carte réalisée à partir des données du
centre national d'assistance et de
prévention de la radicalisation une
carte publiée au lendemain de la
barbarie survenu en isère et qui nous
apprend que 1680 trois individus
présentant des signes de radical
radicalisation religieuse ont été
recensés ce qui représente un triplement
depuis janvier 2014 dans le détail 128
signalement a été effectué en un an
uniquement sur le département des
yvelines les yvelines qui figure parmi
les six départements les plus concernés
par cette situation de la radicalisation
islamiste
le vice-président du conseil d'état en
visite au tribunal administratif de
versailles la dernière fois c'était en
février 2013
pour ce nouveau déplacement jean marc
sauvé est venu avec des bonnes nouvelles
il y aura des fonctionnaires
supplémentaires de quoi soulager un
tribunal administratif qui reçoit et
jugent plus de 9000 affaires par an
catherine du bateau et william l pour
les images
jean-marc sauvé très bien reçu ce lundi
au tribunal administratif de versailles
et pour cause le vice-président du
conseil d'état est venu avec de bonnes
nouvelles
il a annoncé l'arrivée pour le mois de
septembre de 12 magistrats pour combler
les effectifs manquants
en réalité cela correspond à quatre
créations de postes sur les 32 existants
une réponse pour désengorger ce tribunal
qui traite environ 9500 affaires par an
il ya encore en ce moment des dossiers
de l'année 2011 qui n'ont pas été jugés
des dossiers de 2012 sont des dossiers
qui ont trois ou quatre ans d'ancienneté
et qui doivent être réglés c'est un
stock qui est encore trop lourd mais il
faut mesurer le chemin parcouru
car en 2008 ce stock était de 15 mille
affaires il est passé de 15000 à 9500 ce
qui représente un progrès tout à fait
remarquable et il s'agit de poursuivre
et d'achever le redressement
les délais de jugement à versailles sont
donc
trop long ce délai de traitement des
affaires était de 15 mois il ya quelques
années il est passé à 13 mois mais
encore trop élevé par rapport à la
moyenne nationale
parmi les affaires traitées en 2014 40 %
concernaient des contentieux pour les
étrangers 14% le logement et 11% le
domaine fiscal
le nombre des affaires d'étrangers a
fortement augmenté en 2014
notamment parce que je pense que des
préfectures des deux départements qui
sont du ressort du tribunal mais ont pu
accélérer le traitement des dossiers
d'étrangers et ceci a conduit à des
décisions qui ont pu être négative et
donc à l'augmentation des retours il ya
le contentieux du droit au logement
opposable
il ya environ 400 affaires qui ont été
reçus par le tribunal
ça n'a pas beaucoup augmenté l'an passé
mais 400 à faire c'est quand même très
important
et puis le contentieux des impôts a
augmenté que ce soit le les impôts
locaux surtout mais aussi l'impôt sur le
revenu les taxes sur le chiffre
d'affaires ce contentieux a beaucoup
augmenté aussi en cours d'année 2013
sans qu'on soit vraiment en mesure
d'expliquer des raisons le tribunal
administratif de versailles est l'un des
quarante deux tribunaux de ce type en
france
il est compétent en première instance
pour juger les litiges opposant une
personne privée à l'administration
invité de ce journal viviane boussier et
pierre moïse bonsoir à tous les deux
bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes membre du connais ce qu'est le
conseil en développement de saint
quentin en yvelines mais vous êtes en
plateau pour nous parler du plan local
d'urbanisme intercommunal
le pl us y voient déjà précisé donc à
quoi sert ce plan ce qu'est ce plan
local en quoi ce six ans si important
parce que ça semble abstrait et
finalement pour beaucoup de monde et
bien le plan le plan local d'urbanisme
intercommunal et
document d'urbanisme opérationnel qui
s'appliquent sur leur territoire et qui
définit pour une période de quelques
années le droit des sols et lusage qui
peut être fait des sols et c'est en
référence à ce document que l'on fournit
des permis de construire
c'est ça qui va définir le visage de
saint quentin en yvelines à l'avenir en
fait un leader je les différents
chantiers qui vont être réalisés alors
vous avez apporté vos remarques vos
propositions comment vous avez élaboré
justement votre avis qui a été rendue et
qu'on va développer dans quelques
instants
je peux peut-être profité pour préciser
ce qu'est enfin rappeler ce qu'est lé
conseil de développement et de façon de
travailler
ce qui permettra de montrer que ça
revient rapport pour les habitants donc
en fait le conseil de développement je
pense qu'il ya deux choses à retenir il
est vrai il se compose de représentants
de la société civile de saint-quentin
pas et d'autre part sur notre façon de
travailler c'est que on a souvent une
grille de lecture qui est un petit peu
différente de celle qui est habituel et
ça nous permet de raisonner dans une
perspective de long terme est toujours
par rapport aux habitants à ce qu'ils
veulent
et dans cette perspective et je pense
que c'est valable pour tous les avis
dont on va parler peut-être et en
particulier donc le paie lui
comment vous avez travaillé justement
pour faire ce rapport bien pour faire ce
rapport le 10 mai la parole je ne tapez
pas sur la table parce que ça s'apprend
les téléspectateurs nous nous avons
travaillé
en interne et en étroite collaboration
avec la procédure officielle de la
communauté d'agglomération puisque nous
avons participé aux travaux
préliminaires d'autres qui ont permis
l'élaboration des documents et ensuite
par rapport à ces éléments et en
particulier à partir du diagnostic
eh bien nous avons réfléchi en interne
nous avons des réunions de travail en en
ayant pour référence et bien les
documents d'aménagement pour lesquels
nous avions déjà émis des avis par
exemple le schéma directeur
d'ile-de-france les et en parallèle
également le le contrat le contrat de
plan etat-région faire un certain nombre
de documents pour les qui doivent
intervenir dans l'élaboration du pays
lui alors on va pas détaillé en tout
lundi que vous avez rendu le document
complet d'ailleurs je le précise est
disponible sur le site de la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vous pourrez
avoir tout tout le détail mais juste
pour s'arrêter sur certains points déjà
et ce qui marche aujourd'hui à 50 ans né
d'une part ce cas des points positifs
vous avez émis quelques avis pour pour
l'avenir
quelques orientations mais aujourd'hui
saint quentin en yvelines c'est un
territoire une agglomération qui dispose
de nombreux atouts
quels sont les points forts de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines aujourd'hui
c'est saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui est le deuxième pôle le plus
important d'emplois
de l'ouest parisien il y à un taux un
taux d'emploi par rapport au nombre
d'actifs qui est largement supérieur à
tout ce que l'on peut trouver ailleurs
dans la dans la région c'est à dire que
saint quentin en yvelines est un
réservoir d'emplois avec des
caractéristiques d'avenir qui sont la
recherche et l'innovation en particulier
au niveau des entreprises et ça c'est un
élément stratégique qui peut perdre qui
doit permettre à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de se
positionner en d'une manière moteur
motrices par rapport aux développements
futurs qui doit y avoir dans les régions
alors ça c'est pour les points positifs
saint quentin en yvelines a des atouts
et malgré tout il ya aussi être des
difficultés l'une des faiblesses
peut-être la première c'est la disparité
entre les territoires sur les
différentes communes
oui alors justement ça cela fait partie
de d'un autre axe de développement de
réflexion que l'on a actuellement
puisque on réfléchit sur de façon très
générale
l'agrandissement du territoire et
justement c'est un des critères pour
essayer de définir quelles peuvent être
les compétences futures de cette de
cette agglo quels sont justement comment
essayer de réduire au maximum les
diversités le territoire les fractures
de territoire et c'est justement une de
nos grilles de lecture dans ce sujet il
ya un déficit aussi sur l'image sur
l'animation il manque un coeur de ville
quelque chose de deux structures en a
ils n'ont qu'une une véritable identité
parce que c'est un secret
c'est une personne saint quentin en
yvelines n'est pas n'est pas connue et
reconnue en tant que telle
lorsque lorsque des personnes de
l'extérieur arrive 50 ha ouais jouer la
ville de saint quentin
et sur ce point là il est indispensable
de de bien organiser une véritable
identité et c'est un d'entités elle ne
peut se se se montrer que avec avec un
certain nombre de secteurs géographiques
attractifs et des centralités attractive
et un coeur de ville attractif parce que
une ville a besoin d'avoir d'avoir une
âme c'était c'était un des titres de no
dig dig est d'une assemblée que nous
avons fait au printemps parce que c'est
comme ça que les échanges se font entre
les personnes que la vie au quotidien
ce fait et puis il ya une concurrence
aussi qui se développe c'est celle avec
le grand paris le paris saclay également
et il faut saint-quentin-en-yvelines
trouve sa place en milieu tout ça oui
alors c'est aussi un de nos axes de
réflexion pour compléter un petit peu ce
que tu as dit justement avant de passer
à votre question
mais cela c'est justement dans la vie du
pl oui il ya bien comme axes directeurs
faire de 50 à une ville animée
je pense que c'est à nos fans de nos
demandes
bon et l'autre pas pour revenir à ce que
vous disiez oui la ligne 18 élus le
manque d'attractivité ça se fait sentir
parce que pour vous la ligne 18
justement si je reprends le point de la
vie vous avez pu émettre sa vanessa va
desservir uniquement la frange est oui
dans l'agglomération et donc c'est pas
suffisant
c'est pas suffisant c'est pas suffisant
puisque saint quentin c'est et d'autre
part c'est aussi appelé à grandir vers
les villes de plaisir les clairanencs
donc c'est il ya un déséquilibre là qui
ne peut faire qu'à grandir justement les
disparités dont vous parlez et il nous
demande c'est pas seulement ceux ci
c'est aussi peut-être une deuxième gare
pourquoi donc peut-être faire tout à
fait elle pas le le le
pour que le territoire de saint quentin
soit irrigué une gare située en
périphérie est largement insuffisante et
en particulier une gare qui est
complètement extérieur ou différents
pôles d'attractivité qui existe
aujourd'hui et qui aussi existeront
demain parce que les pôles de
développement qui sont prévus sur le
territoire de saint quentin
son corps ainsi que sur l'ensemble du
territoire et pas uniquement sur sa
frange est ce qui m'amène à un autre
point que j'ai relevées dans la vie vous
avez émis vous soulignez que la région à
l'état ne prête pas une attention à la
hauteur du rôle de 50 ans les miennes
exactement
exactement et c'est aussi une 2 x 10 ans
un de nos axes de réflexion monsieur
quand on réfléchisse le territoire de
saint quentin ne se contente pas de le
voir tel qu'il est dans ces sept
communes et futurs douze communes mais
aussi trouvé sa place dans une
perspective plus large et le codé ski et
en faisant partie la coordination
francilienne des conseils développement
a aussi comme comme axe de réflexion
trouver sa place de la société civile
dans cette future grande agglomération
et mettre apple juste très concrètement
pour répondre à notre question si on lit
le contrat de plan état région qui
engage ces deux politiques etc les
collectivités vis-à-vis des
collectivités locales
eh bien les cycles et les financements
prévus pour notre territoire
ils sont très très faibles et ne sont
pas justement à la hauteur dont
seulement des attentes mais 10 de besoin
l'arrivée des nouvelles communes au sein
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines ça va changer quelque chose et
des inquiétudes à avoir au contraire ça
sera un bol d'air pour poursuivre le
développement des logements par exemple
organisé par sport
je crois qu répondent tous les deux
c'est un peu être un bol d'air ça peut
c'est un projet à projet c'est un vrai
projet à construire et donc avec toutes
les limites et les mairies les essais
noir d'impro des projets et bien mieux
que que ce projet correspond aussi aux
attentes des oscillations les
différentes remarques proposition vous
avez pu émettre dans quelle mesure on
peut attendre qu'elle soit finalement
retenu écouter parce que vous êtes un
conseil en développement exactement que
ce sont
des propositions en ce sens que des
propositions donc mais ce qu'on entend
que les élus lisent les avis tient du
conte je sais pas jusqu'où on peut aller
dans cette danse être opérationnel de
quoi faire avec car ce sens il s'en tire
sans lui c'est le sentiment que l'on a
eue après la présentation des rapports
d'activités les avis ont bien été
justement les aide à la décision et
après les élus prennent leurs décisions
je crois que si vous voulez consulter le
rapport cet avis du code skis et les
autres aussi sur notamment le pmi mais
je vous disais des autres et les autres
documents sur lesquels vous avez planché
c'est à consulter sur le site internet
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines merci à tous les deux nous
venons à l'actualité du jour est une
nouvelle de protestation des parents
d'élèves de trappes sur la suppression
de l'étude après l'école et la fin de la
gratuité est de la tranche horaire de
15h30 à 16h30
et ce dès la rentrée prochaine une
action a été organisée hier soir dans la
mairie est les représentants des parents
d'élèves avaient invité leurs enfants à
faire lors le son dans le hall pour
manifester
le maire de trappes guy malandain les a
ensuite reçu pour une réunion le
reportage est signé mickaël millero et
elodie moines ce lundi soir les parents
d'élèves de trappes et leurs enfants se
sont déplacés en nombre à la mairie
protestent toujours contre la
suppression de l'étude après l'école et
la fin de la gratuité de la tranche
horaire de 15h30 à 16h30 dès la rentrée
prochaine
que les familles un peu plus à l'aise
tout le monde est concerné pour renouer
le dialogue après une première
manifestation lors du dernier conseil
municipal le maire de la commune guy
malandain a organisé une réunion avec
les représentants des parents d'élèves
objectif de cette rencontre explique
qu'il est mesuré surtout rassurer et lui
a également proposé des solutions aux
parents d'élèves concernant le temps
d'étude la municipalité et en aidant
travail avec l'éducation nationale pour
pour mettre en place un temps de
réflexion sur le temps scolaire ce qui
permettrait dit surin
deux déjà de réduire le temps
d'apprentissage et travail intellectuel
de l'enfant sur la journée peut faire
ces révisions sur un temps où l'enfant
un petit peu moins réceptifs je suis pas
forte en maths mais une demi heure en
moins ça va être difficile de déterminer
un programme donc encore une fois il va
être défavorisés en apprentissage ne
vont pas tout faire en ce qui concerne
la gratuité de la tranche horaire 15h30
16h30 le maire affirme qu'il n'y aura
pas de coûts supplémentaires pour les
familles à la rentrée prochaine
et c'est le même tarif pour trois heures
que c'était pour deux ans et avec en
plus on a ajouté ce que je disais tout à
l'heure une baisse par enfant pour le
deuxième enfant le troisième enfant pour
faciliter aux gens une association
parents d'élèves qui se permet de jouer
avec les enfants pour faire valoir ses
revendications
surtout quand on sait non fondées c'est
inacceptable et le deuxième point c'est
aussi inaltérable de raconter ce qu'il
n'est pas il ya une délibération il ya
une note explicative
il ya une lettre du maire qui précise
les choses l'association a pété les
parents d'élèves organiseront une
nouvelle action ce vendredi 3 juillet
nous changeons de communes nous partons
pour plaisir ou la ville a signé
vendredi dernier un contrat pour agir en
faveur du quartier du valais bout
identifié comme un quartier en
géographie prioritaire dès 2014 par
françois lamy ministre de la ville à
l'époque mélanie poker s'appuyer sur
trois piliers lutte contre la
discrimination l'équité entre hommes et
femmes et la laïcité le quartier du
vélib ou fait désormais l'objet d'un
contrat de ville partenariat signé par
la commune l'état mais aussi différentes
institutions comme pôle emploi le
rectorat de versailles ou encore
l'opievoy les médiateurs vont être mis
en place la maison de la réussite
éducative est là pour accompagner les
familles mais en parallèle de ça il ya
effectivement l'anru qui arrive
aujourd'hui sur la ville de plaisir et
il doit y avoir un véritable action sur
tout ce qui est habitat au niveau de la
ville de la ville et du quartier
aujourd'hui ce qui est important c'est
de trouver le moyen de faire du vivre
ensemble et puis de donner des moyens
aussi pour qui
y'a respectueux des uns et des autres et
que surtout le quartier soit reconnu
comme un quartier comme un autre le
quartier du val hibou ce sont 1000 107
logements au coeur de la commune les
4000 habitants représente 12 5% de la
population plaisir oise
l'état apportera sa contribution à
hauteur de 5,7 millions d'euros par an
c'est une politique de l'état de faire
en sorte que de lutter contre les
discriminations et dans des quartiers
qu'ils ne vont pas très bien et donc le
valley bout avec un action carroyage sur
200 m 200 m avec les revenus médians est
sorti dans les quartiers à suivre et à
sur lequel il fallait travailler donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
mis en place un travail partenarial pour
d'abord faire le diagnostic du quercy
qu'on connaissait bien puisqu'il était
déjà un géographie prioritaire
précédemment mais savoir ce qu'il
fallait continuer à faire avec l axe sur
quels axes travailler 150 actions
verront le jour certaines ont déjà
commencé comme le lancement le 4 mars
mal conseil citoyen indépendant du
conseil municipal
le contrat de ville est signée pour une
durée de six ans c'est une première la
préfecture des yvelines a ouvert ses
jardins dans le cadre de la fête des
sports avéré une véritable garden party
avec près de 150 jeunes et un seul mot
d'ordre favoriser le vivre ensemble
mercredi dernier les jardins de la
préfecture de versailles étaient en fait
les ja du département de tous âges sont
venus participer à la première grande
journée de sport aujourd'hui on a décidé
de faire une grande fête du sport des
années précédentes on aurait le sport
uniquement en honorant les sportifs ou
les jeunes qui avaient leur bafa
jours-ci il faut mettre un peu de vie
dans tout ça l'idée aujourd'hui c'était
de montrer un peu tout ce qu'ils font
tout ce qu'ils savent faire tout ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire
parce que bien souvent ils le font dans
leur quartier mais ils ne sont pas vus
par des gens qui fréquentent peut-être
plus la préfecture
après ces dix ans d'engagement à la
cohésion sociale et à la jeunesse
est-elle carrasso rotman a fait ses
adieux aux jeunes et aux associations
présentes à cette occasion des
animations sportives ont été installés
un mur d'escaladé ring de boxe ou encore
une scène où se produisent de jeunes
poètes et danseurs une journée pour
honorer le sport sous toutes ses
facettes
jasmine par exemple est venu pour
profiter de la boxe mais aussi présenter
l'association dont elle fait partie
pour inciter les jeunes à faire des
choses de même pas que pendant qu'on a
là des quartiers où les jeunes très bon
on sait rien alors là on est vraiment on
se réunit c'est comme une famille on
fait des choses sur la ville on est
présents et ont montré la jeunesse est
l'importance sociale c'est quand même
impressionnant
ouais c'est impressionnant de voir comme
dans nos mairies mais c'est trop
demander aux 4,7 shawn était une
réussite pour le préfet qui souhaite
également inciter les jeunes à s'engager
davantage pour le service civique le
gouvernement cette année a souhaité que
l'on augmente significativement le
nombre de jeunes en service civique pour
vous dans le département nous sommes là
évidemment de cette démarche là on va
doubler le nombre de service civique que
ses dents en 2015 l'aja l'émission qui
s'occupe de faire agréer des employeurs
et on appelle jeunes qui sont
volontaires donc les emplois des jeunes
ça va marcher et on va avoir beaucoup de
s'investir et 150 jeunes et plus de 20
associations tout ceci découvert pour la
première fois les jardins de la
préfecture et des roses si cher au look
internet des images d'une autre
animation à présent pour refermer ce
journal c'est à montigny le bretonneux
dans le cadre de l'opération parole de
jardiniers plusieurs manifestations
organisées autour de l'eau et au regard
de la météo c'est plutôt bienvenu ce
week end le public avait rendez vous à
l'office de tourisme avec l'association
saint-quentinoise ville verte
l'association intervient en milieu
scolaire dans un but pédagogique
ce samedi donc rencontre avec cindy
gaudin qui nous explique le parcours de
l'eau yvelinoise d'où vient-elle eua tel
lot elle est captée soit en nappes
souterraines soit dans le milieu naturel
par exemple nous vivent comme des
rivières sur l'exemple de saint quentin
en yvelines
l'eau allait capter en profondeur dans
les nappes souterraines du côté de
croatie lors ensuite elle va être envoyé
dans une usine de nettoyage en
l'occurrence pour 1,50 en yvelines c'est
du côté de versailles donc l'ol va
arriver elle va passer par tout un
système de grille qui vont retenir des
plus grosses particules jusqu'aux plus
petites elles vont passer donc dans
différents bâtiments jusqu'à la dernière
étape une chloration qui permettra de
stabiliser l'eau potable jusqu'à son
approvisionnement en direction des
ménages par contre juste avant il faut
qu'elles puissent est stockée pour
pouvoir être envoyés dans les ménages
par l'intermédiaire d'un château d'eau
après que l'eau soit arrivé au niveau
des îles donc immeubles maisons sur la
collectivité
une fois que l'eau a été consommée est
souillée elle va se rediriger un nouveau
vers une station d'épuration en
l'occurrence sur saint quentin ça
pourrait être l'une de ses usines
d'épuration comme celle des longs cours
l'eau va à nouveau arriver et subir
différents traitements
donc elle va re subir des phases de
dégrillage on va ajouter des bactéries
également pour pouvoir neutraliser
certaines substances qui serait néfaste
ci ont restitué l'eau en milieu naturel
et une fois qu'elle sera passée dans
tous ces différents bassins elle sera
restituée en milieu naturel
la seule chose et ans et que l'eau à la
sortie ne sera pas potable
voilà donc non la potabilité pour nous
non larrons ne restitue pas mieux
naturel potabilisée voilà pour ces
explications c'est la fin de cette
édition je vous retrouve dans quelques
minutes pour le 7-8 politique dernière
émission de la saison il sera question
des régionales très largement mais aussi
de la création d'un groupe l'est
républicain à saint quentin en yvelines
le journal revient demain mercredi aux
horaires habituels excellente soirée